live from the Berlin Wall on the most
historic night in this Wall's history it
is perhaps the most important
announcement made in Central Europe
since the end of World War II everything
seemed really simple on November the 9th
1989 in 1989 communism's iron grip
weakened as uprisings took place from
Berlin to Beijing with vastly different
results everybody thought China would
get more liberal as it became richer no
one thought it would go the other way
the people's Liberation Army was gunning
down protesters in beijing's jiman
square it was like being in a war zone
but while the forward momentum could not
be denied there were new complications
Yet to Come the economy was in shambles
in the end I think that was what creates
the opportunity for Vladimir Putin
tanaman square is why today China has a
real
dictatorship back in in
1989 we envisioned a world free of Cold
War tensions that's not the case today
history has a kind of fluidity that when
we think one thing is going to happen
results often times end up anything but
what we
expect the world as I had known it all
of my adult life changed and changed
fundamentally beginning in 1989
[Music]
in man's heart if not in fact the day of
the dictator is over great nations of
the world are moving toward democracy
through the door to
freedom in the latter half of the 20th
Century the United States and the Soviet
Union were perpetually engaged in a
global
Showdown some thought it would lead to
World War II until the late 80s when a
new kind of Soviet leader emerged the
course set by President gorbachov
involves changes in political structure
ideology legal practices and popular
attitudes as well of course as the
economy mik gorbachov will be traded
very very very well by history garbage
decided they would not keep the empire
together through the use of
force for many decades US presidents
believed in the Domino Theory if one
nation fell to Communism nearby nations
would quickly follow
suit but in 1989 the opposite happened a
communist country turned Democratic and
other countries fell in its
weight 198 89 as the year in which all
of this fundamental reform began and one
of the first things that happened was
that Poland held an
election in Poland an independent labor
union called solidarity pressured the
country's Communist government into
holding a free
election the government ultimately
agreed to open the polls but thought it
would be just for show the communist
thought they had rigged these elections
they were counting on the fact that they
had enough political muscle to make sure
that solidarity would be a minority not
a
majority but the people themselves were
so caught up in the possibility that
things could really change I've never
seen that kind of
enthusiasm they had these posters for
the June 4th election with um picture of
Gary Cooper saying in Polish this is
high
news
solidarity won that election they won it
overwhelmingly with a guy named El
Valencia leading the charge by the end
of the summer Poland had democratically
exited communist Rule and it was the
first country in Eastern Europe to do
this gorbachov didn't stand in the way
and with Poland the once impenetrable
Iron Curtain suddenly had a big hole in
it to those who think that dreams can be
forever repressed
I say let them look at Poland for here
in Poland the dream is
alive the same day Poland cast its vote
for democracy another historic event was
unfolding in
China for months prior Chinese citizens
had been protesting communist rule a
visit by Mel gorbachov in May brought
worldwide attention to the demonstration
Soviet president gorbachov is flying to
China at this hour for the first sinos
Soviet Summit meeting in 30 years but
even as China's communist leaders
prepare to receive the Soviet communist
leader they've had to contend with
students demanding Democratic
reforms in 1989 gorbachov is coming to
meet dang ping the two leaders are going
to meet that visit by gorbachov feeds
the fire in Beijing because a thousand
foreign correspondents show up
I was the foreign correspondent in
Beijing I was covering this trip
gorbachov was trying to loosen controls
in the Soviet Union gorbachov said let's
let in a little freedom and we'll worry
about the economy later now in China
they had decided to loosen the economy
they were bringing in capitalism people
were living really well and there were
lots of consumer goods but people start
to want more and and what they wanted
was
democracy so people in China were
protesting gorbachov his motorcade gets
stopped because the whole of Beijing is
out in the streets blocking everything
and the Chinese protesters are getting
on International television I want to
say to the government what we are want
is the only the Democracy only the
freedom of the speech gorbachov's visit
inspired more people to join the
protests
calling for economic reform and
political Freedom it was really
interesting to watch China try to figure
out what do we do with this cuz that
level of demonstration was unprecedented
in sort of modern Chinese history
China's leaders were humiliated when
students occupied tianan Square in
Beijing during gorbachov's visit within
hours of gorbachov's departure the
Chinese leadership is really mad Premier
Lee pong he's a hard liner he gets on
television and that's when he declares
martial
law that's when they bring in the
Army the situation around tianan Square
in Beijing grows more complicated and
more tense the government may be
planning to try to clear the square
troops carrying automatic weapons and
wearing Battle Gear have been
positioned I saw the trucks coming in so
we went in the square and I interviewed
people as journalists we don't quite
understand what's really happening and
then on the night of June 3rd they had
orders to take the square using any
means
possible they shot their way into the
square the tanks rolled through and I
was really
scared
one of the tanks started up his engine
and ran over some of the
students it was like being in a war
zone the estimates of how many Chinese
were killed and injured in yesterday's
brutal assault on their movement for
democracy very widely but it is believed
that there were hundreds of deaths and
[Music]
injuries by 6:00 a.m. on June 4th
thousands of Chinese citizens had been
beaten or killed the exact number
reported still in
dispute the Army had cleared tanaman
square of protesters but the resistance
would continue showing the world an
indelible moment of
defiance Monday I can't believe what
I've seen and I go outside and the whole
row of Tanks is coming down the
boulevard of Eternal peace and there's
this guy
with a little shopping bag and and he's
right in front of the lead tank and I'm
going he's going to be
squashed and then all of a sudden the
tank turns off the motor and doesn't go
forward that may be one of the on a tiny
list of the most important images from
the 20th
century everybody knows it's TN men
Square it doesn't matter how big the gun
is if you're standing up for the right
stuff ten man was a negative event and
garbatov felt well that's not going to
happen in the Soviet
Union I think he could tell that there
was no future for communism
anymore I think if he hadn't had his
Summit with d XA ping just at that
moment maybe the world history would
have been
different
in 1961 the Berlin Wall was built to
separate East and West Germany a literal
division of Communism and
democracy but in the summer of 1989
Austria and Hungary opened their borders
so East Germans could cross into the
Democratic West Germany the Iron Curtain
was lifting and many wondered how much
longer until the wall would
fall I was based in Vienna reporting on
Eastern Europe when Hungary and Austria
opened its gates in May of 1989 this
really was actually the end of the Iron
Curtain it was a clear signal that
unrest was really spreading to East
Germany gorbachov's visit to East
Germany that October came at an awkward
moment and provided a dramatic and
unexpected policy shift the most
important thing that had happened right
up to that time was when gorbachov had
been asked about something having to do
with East Germany and gorbachov said
policy for East Germany is made in
Berlin not in Moscow which was a clear
signal I think to people that the
Soviets were not going to call their
troops out of the barracks in East
Germany in central leig banners calling
for free elections free travel and a
free press and the people demanding new
leadership and on their lips the name of
one man who symbolizes the change in the
Communist World president
gorbachov the demonstration is the
biggest threat yet to the stability of
the government there was so much
pressure on the East German leaders and
you could just feel this this thing is
starting to really
unravel in November of 1989 the East
German Central Committee gathered
together and announced the country's new
travel regulations
the press conference would have a
surprise ending the man who was sent out
to explain the new travel regulations G
chabowski we now know had not been at
one of the key meetings he had a bunch
of papers shoved into his hand and went
out for this press conference I was
there somebody asked are we here that
you're thinking of adopting new travel
rules and he said oh yes and started to
read
them
and then shovsky was asked by a
journalist well and so when does this
start and he looked at his papers and
said basically was trying to say we're
going to head toward
this but he says the word immediately by
mistake it's done and then we suddenly
heard West German television say oh and
we hear that it's also possible at
Checkpoint Charlie to get across and I
just turned to my colleague and I said
Checkpoint Charlie I mean if that's true
then the whole thing is
over that night there were about 150
people there they were a good SP ired
and they weren't rebellious or crazy in
any way the guards who had been taught
to defend that border with their life if
they needed to were confused they had no
orders because it was all a mistake so
they didn't know what to
do and the Border guards realized that I
was a journalist they may not have known
what to do to defend the wall but they
knew for sure that a western journalist
was not welcome in the East German
border Zone they opened this St that led
to this very narrow passageway out and
sort of shoved me into it and together
with me this woman squeezed her way in
she was East German she had papers to
visit the West we both gave our
passports into this sort of pimple
Border guard and then he looked at hers
and said but it's only valid on the 17th
of November and I just remember shouting
at this guy in German saying but look
around you man history is happening what
difference does it make he sort of
shrugged pressed a
button the door to the West opened to
us and that's how I know that I came
across checkpoint Charley that night
with the first East German to cross it
was an amazing moment it was actually
the only moment in my life when I have
pinched myself to see am I really here
or am I dreaming this once the doors
were open the influx was huge
astonishing news from East Germany where
the East German authorities have said in
essence that the Berlin Wall doesn't
mean anything anymore it is perhaps the
most important announcement made in
Central Europe since the end of World
War II certainly since the wall went up
live from the Berlin Wall on the most
historic night in this Wall's history
the people are here to celebrate freedom
for the East Germans freedom to travel
primary right for people anywhere in the
world the joy of unexpected Liberation
you'd been let out of jail everything
seemed really simple on November the 9th
1989 this wall that had been standing
since
1961 had fallen and that was just a
simple really easy to understand human
message to see that wall crack people
with hammers and chip chisels and out
there and partying and drinking
champagne on the precipice of the wall
it was it was
unimaginable but not everyone was happy
with this turn of
events Vladimir Putin witnessed the fall
of the Berlin Wall as a KGB agent in
Dresden in East Germany he saw the mob
come into those
headquarters Putin saw that as a
collapse in Soviet order and must have
wondered what was going to take its
place history has a kind of fluidity
that when we think one thing is going to
happen the results often times end up
anything but what we
expect Boris yelton a political Outcast
two years ago was swept back into high
political office today Soviet analysts
are calling it a victory for democracy
and reform results are still preliminary
but election officials now say that
Boris yelson will be Russia's first
elected
president in June of 1991 Boris yelton
became Russia's first democratically
elected leader but his new economic
system would prove difficult to control
just a few well-connected oligarchs
ultimately seized control of Russia's
major industries while inflation soared
and gross domestic product fell each and
every year he was in
power we did not anticipate nor did the
Soviets the total implosion of the
Soviet Union nobody saw that
coming yelon did nothing really he took
over from gorbage it it descended into
chaos what they did was they opened up
the Soviet economy and sold all the raw
materials to the the
oligarchs in the meantime you don't have
a developed economy Russians are quite
poor whenever you have an economy in
disaster then people want a strong man
to come in and at least you know make
the trains run on
[Music]
time I was in Russia after the
dissolution of the Soviet Union the
economy was in shambles the country was
in really really tough shape for a lot
of people there it was really tough
times in the end I think that was what
creates the opportunity for Vladimir
Putin in Moscow today an unprecedented
peaceful passing of power between
democratically elected leaders along
with the Office of the President
Vladimir Putin is inheriting a vast
array of serious problems shortly after
he became Russia's President Putin
started displaying a leadership style
that seemed like it was from a bygone
era
in just his first year in office the
government raided a TV News Network ties
with Fidel Castro were reestablished and
many believe Putin laid the foundation
for his own fortunes aligning himself
with Russia's oligarchs one sure way to
coales domestic support is to be able to
point to an outside enemy and so NATO
became the enemy uh the West became the
enemy the United States became the enemy
Russian president Vlad PR Putin made his
first visit since Russia annexed Crimea
from Ukraine Russia sent more troops
tanks and military vehicles into eastern
Ukraine today the Kremlin claims there
is no proof that Moscow interfered in
the 2016 US election confrontation in
the skies between us fighter jets and
nuclear capable Russian bombers not far
from American Shores people ask me all
the time are we in another cold war and
my answer to that is absolutely we are
when we have Russian Jets buzzing our
aircraft and ships there's no other way
to look at it back in 1989 we envisioned
a world that would be free of Cold War
tensions that's not the case
today in Russia and in China political
system is still a very much as closed as
it was then in China the leaders saw
what happened to the Soviet Union and to
the Eastern block and they actually
double down on everything which is why
today I think China has a real
dictatorship in cin ping he saw what
gorbachov did so they sort of fed off
each other and they each took away a
different lesson everybody thought China
would get more liberal as it became
richer no one thought it would go the
other way the jury is still out on what
whether or not this wonderful economic
model that they've created can continue
to survive without any political Freedom
you can't have that economic freedom
without giving the people political
Freedom as
well it's very hard to predict the
future of
China if China has capitalism which it
has how long can it have a Communist
Party running it and we saw in the
Soviet Union how it just collapsed
overnight
any day now the whole thing can fall
apart in China they could have democracy
true democracy and truly free markets is
a proven Paradigm and it will succeed in
my view for the next 30 years as
well I think the lessons of 1989 for the
world is that we have to treasure the
Democracy we have because it's fragile
and it can easily be subverted
don't take democracy for
[Music]
granted